I've been in East Palestine this week
talking to Residents who were forced to
evacuate after a derailment of a Norfolk
Southern Train on February 3rd
residents were told that they could
return home but since they've been back
many have concerns about being back in
their homes and they're concerned about
smells and the potential for health
effects from chemicals that were
released during the derailment right now
there's sort of just this kind of cloud
of concern that's hanging over the town
on Friday February 3rd around 9pm a
Norfolk Southern Train derailed in the
small village of East Palestine Ohio
which is on the border with Pennsylvania
as soon as the derailment occurred
police and other officials came through
the town and told people that they had
to evacuate immediately
Monday February 6th Norfolk Southern
said that it would have to breach five
tanker cars containing Vinyl chloride to
prevent a potentially catastrophic
explosion
owners they don't have the answers to
give us because I don't think they know
they're not getting the straight answers
either
residents in East Palestine and
surrounding areas pack the school
gymnasium Wednesday night to seek
answers we're trying to get information
out to our services everybody's
concerned I'm concerned but you know
it's not worth of seven here it's the
EPA the people have been working with us
trying to get our citizens back into
their home safe
[Applause]
no particulate map it was just a big run
around like I feel like a lot of the
questions that were asked were people's
rantings and just speaking in circles
the answers that were given were things
that we've already been told
Norfolk Southern declined to send
representatives to the town hall citing
safety concerns
the railroad said it has distributed 1.5
million dollars directly to more than a
thousand families and some businesses
and has established a one million dollar
fund available immediately to the
community
one of the chemicals released in the
train derailment was vinyl chloride
which the National Cancer Institute says
is associated with a higher risk of
liver cancer
Federal and State Environmental
Regulators say they're going to continue
to monitor the air quality and water in
the area to ensure that it's safe for
Citizens what we have discussed covered
through the testing and sampling that's
been done is that very early on
you know we we have estimated based on
our sampling and modeling about 3 500
dead fish across that space across those
streams tributaries waterways the
administrator for the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency visited Thursday let
me be clear EPA will exercise our
oversight and our enforcement Authority
under the law to be sure we are getting
the result that the community deserves
so far the EPA has said that air
monitoring has showed no levels of
concern from chemicals released into the
air the EPA has also said that the water
is safe to drink in East Palestine from
the Municipal Water facility
[Music]
and just
just plumbers that have to till their
soil up many residents want testing
inside their homes which is being done
but even when it is being done they're
they're still kind of distrustful about
those results at this point